there is a BBC correspondent his name is
Mark lowen who just posted a picture of
him and his gay partner and a little
baby in an airport and this guy says
quote after six weeks in wonderful and
tearful farewells to our incredible
surrogate and friend it's time to go
home to Lisbon with our new family
member our most beautiful hand luggage
Canada you are a shining light of
democracy and equality thank you for
letting us fulfill our dream
and he is fulfilling a dream I have no
doubt that Mark lowen this BBC
correspondent is fulfilling his dream of
having a child with his gay lover
the cost of fulfilling that dream was
ripping a baby away from his mother
that was the cost
and this guy many other people in this
country are choosing to pursue that
dream that fantasy that delusion that
two men can be the same thing as a man
and a woman who are married and have a
family and have children
many many men and some women
are choosing to pursue that dream at the
cost of
tearing a newborn little child away from
his natural mother it's one of the worst
things that you can possibly do to
anybody on Earth if you've ever spent
any time if you have children yourself
you ever spent time as a little baby if
you were ever a kid once you might
remember some of this
little babies need their mothers and
when these very very selfish gay men
decide that they are going to put their
own
disordered desires
their disordered sexual desires and
their perfectly normal well-ordered
natural desire for a family when they
are going to just Mash those two things
up and the person who's gonna have to
pay the price for that is the little
baby who gets robbed of his mother that
is a terrible evil thing to do and
Society obviously should not tolerate
that at all but you're not really
allowed to say that anymore
we have to all pretend we have to be
just like
we talked about this yesterday on the
show all the people watching that
transgender ice skater who's a who's an
older man an older out of shape man
who's now pretending to be a woman and
trying to skate around during an ice
skating competition from Finland and he
can't really do it and then he falls
down and he can't get up and that's kind
of funny it's sad but it's funny it's
mostly funny this is just mostly sad
and it is a reminder
that
people do not have a right to a child
when we're talking about family when
we're talking about procreation the only
people who can be said to have any
rights whatsoever are the children a
child has a right to his natural mother
and father who are united together in
marriage in perpetuity and marriage is
an institution that unites husbands and
wives for the good of the spouses and
for the sake of the generation and
education of children gay men have no
right to purchase to rent the wombs of
poor women and to purchase the eggs of
poor women and to create children with
the express intent of of robbing those
children of their natural mothers that's
a really evil awful thing to do and I I
don't think that most of the people who
do this even really think about it I
don't think Mark lowen has ever really
considered that too much but
nevertheless it's a really evil thing to
do babies need their mothers okay and
some people have responded to this they
said well Michael
do you think that would you say the same
thing about heterosexual surrogacy
you're uh you sound like a big phobe you
know you sound like a big bigot well
look it obviously is different
it is worse when gay men and lesbian
women and single parents for that matter
do this than when a married couple does
this but it's all bad we should not be
renting the wombs of poor women and
purchasing the eggs of other women in
some cases
and creating children in in test tubes
to satisfy our own desires it has lots
of effects that people don't like to
take account of namely
it usually
involves the creation of lots of embryos
lots of little human beings who are then
locked away in freezers forever and ever
but beyond that
it it establishes the domination of
Technology over the origin and Destiny
of human life and corporations over the
origin and Destiny of human life and
that's and the state sometimes over the
origin of Destiny of human life and
that's a terrible thing to do this is
this is in on the one hand a kind of
cultural Marxism a radical dismantling
of our of our culture along new
atheistic absurd lines that's definitely
part of what's happening this is also
capitalism run amok the fact that we're
now treating women as Commodities as as
as places to be rented and that we're
treating eggs and sperm as Commodities
and that we're treating little kids as
Commodities are perfect most beautiful
new hand luggage
little pets little toys little doddles
to ornament are are consumerist lives
absolutely awful stuff don't do it I'm
sure I'm sure there are people who have
engaged in this who now regret it and
that's very sad and you got to make the
best of a bad situation for people I
know there are plenty of gay people who
listen to this show and who are
considering these things don't do it you
might not realize how evil it is now but
it is evil do not do it have I made
myself clear
I hope that I have speaking of children
Minnesota has just decided to legalize
abortion
at any point in pregnancy
this according to Minnesota quote every
individual who becomes pregnant has a
fundamental right to continue the
pregnancy and give birth or obtain an
abortion and to make autonomous
decisions about how to exercise this
fundamental right this is the protect
reproductive options act every Democrat
in the Minnesota state house voted for
this and every Republican opposed it and
the governor who's a Democrat says he'll
sign it into law
this now means that Minnesota is in the
same league as North Korea and communist
China when it comes to abortion much
much more radical than pretty much every
other country on Earth other than
North Korea China and Canada Canada
actually is also also there as well now
what the libs will tell you what the
pro-abortion people will tell you is
you fear-mongering conservatives you
like to pretend that abortions happen
late in pregnancies you like to pretend
that there could be abortions in the
ninth month of pregnancy but that just
doesn't happen you're worried about a
problem that doesn't exist
and the way that you know that this
argument is completely empty and
dishonest is that they changed the law
if this doesn't happen
why would they change the law
if this doesn't happen why did they
change the law to do this in New York
why did they change the law in Virginia
why did they now change the law in
Minnesota specifically to legalize
abortion at any point in pregnancy right
up until the moment of birth
you should put that argument right back
in their face and you say okay it
doesn't happen good then vote against
the law well it's not going to do
anything
so the law is totally ineffective isn't
it it's not going to have any effect in
the real oh it will why because it does
happen this reminds me of when Nancy
Pelosi said that the the wall that Trump
wanted to build on our Southern border
is cruel and inhumane and a terrible
thing to do and a violation of Human
Rights and also wolves don't work hold
on
I mean she has it if the walls don't
work then the wall is obviously not
inhumane and cruel and terrible in a
violation of Human Rights
if the wall is all of those things then
clearly the Wall Works it's got some
effect it's the same thing here
they are passing these laws
because late-term abortions do happen
and the libs don't want to defend
late-term abortions on the merits so
they say hey look over here it doesn't
really happen this is a made-up problem
don't listen to the conservatives and
then with their other hand they're
signing these barbaric laws into effect
[Music]